what is going on there reject nation greg here
today before yes john is out of commission at
the moment yeah he's recovering from
surgery wish him well in the comments
currently working off of a little bit of
an all-nighter 9 20 in the morning at the
moment then this moon night spot dropped
and i was like ah it's just 30 seconds
long maybe there's something new in it and then
sure enough when you think that you get a whole
bunch of dms of people going actually greg
there's a whole lot of new footage in here
it's like they all read in my mind which is one of
my split personalities anyway yeah if you guys can
leave a like that'd be very much appreciated
i'm gonna keep this one short today but it's
moon night man keep a lookout for our reactions
we'll be covering them on the channel as usual
stephen do you weren't supposed to see any
of this oh cool you sure you want to know
damn that costume cannot tell the
difference between life and dreams
am i like some sort of secret agent it's a little
more complicated than that marvel studios only
on disney plus oh man i gotta watch that again
that just woke me up we can't watch that again
stephen you weren't supposed to see any of
this what are you you sure you want to know
who am i you sure you want to know i cannot
get over how great that costume looks
between my waking life and dreams
am i like some sort of secret agent
it's a little more complicated than that
marvel studios moon night only on disney plus
i wonder if oscar isaac got multiple paychecks
because i know that sometimes happens with people
with actors if they have to play like they play
twins for example you'll get paychecks for playing
two separate characters and i'm wondering if in
this case it did because here he's you know he's
playing steven and he's playing mark spector
so probably not though it's probably not the same
thing so they all derive from the same guy i mean
my favorite parts about it's like as cool as the
costume looks so much as i eat that [ __ ] up but
my favorite part of it is of course scene that's
why it's called secret agent that makes a lot of
sense it's mark spector being a cia agent it's all
starting to click in the nugget here anyway yeah
when you look at this with the ways handling
conversations by themselves there's always a
variety of ways you can handle that you can just
have like do some split screen with two of them
in the same room or it can look like awkward
cgi green screen stuff going on considering the
fact that you look at the other trailers and they
already have so much ominous imagery with mirrors
and reflections and whatnot have him interact with
himself in sort of this obscure reflection i think
is actually a great way to handle that it seems
like for sure that the main character here will be
stephen grant at least at the kickoff point that
makes me curious how the season itself will end
like will this season end now the dominant
personality you'll be hanging out with the
audience will be with is going to be mark spector
or will it still continue to be steven knight
because i like the approach of steven knight is
completely unaware of the other personalities
that personality is where you're going to be the
audience decipher to experience this unraveling
of not only the physical mystery surrounding
him but also the internal mysteries as well
i think that's really clever and part of the
excitement with the announcement of moon knight
is oscar isaac doing multiple personalities
getting to really showcase some of that acting
range watch him interact with himself and
then so seeing that here in this clip was
like my favorite element of it while you
get all the [ __ ] and moon night stuff
as well because even in that dialogue exchange
you sort of get this sense that mark is trying
to protect steven which is cool to me because
you're gonna actually see a relationship
form with them versus like hey look at the oscar
isaac show of acting talent you're gonna see a
relationship of interaction with each other yeah
the way to capture moonlight man he's just there's
something that's so uh godlike about the way he
looks oh it's beautiful beautiful anyway thank you
guys so much for being here um i will catch you
guys soon keep looking for our moon now reactions
you